on Wednesday a medical examiner
determined Neely's uh his death was a
homicide however that does not mean the
case will be prosecuted as a homicide
okay that's the stupidest bit of writing
I've ever heard as a murderer they mean
homicide means death caused by person it
doesn't mean criminal uh so what they're
trying to say is though the the the the
death was worldly homicide it does not
mean the case will be prosecuted as a
murder
that is up to the uh Manhattan day's
office which is investigating but I
suppose I'm probably being a little bit
too harsh because you can uh they're not
being clear here you could make the
argument there's Reckless homicide
there's negligent homicide and so what
they're saying is it's not clear that he
will be criminally charged they probably
just should have said they're going to
say as a part of our rigorous ongoing
investigation we'll review the medical
examiner's report assess all available
video and photo footage identify and
interview as many witnesses as possible
and obtain additional medical records
read a statement from a spokesperson for
the D.A so we've got video coming out of
New York protesters uh I believe this
was yesterday where uh we're seen in the
streets and the police made some arrests